so now you can all tell me what is the
shape that they are looking at it's a
cube all right can you just draw a
little cube for me that's a terrible
cube let's try that again
all right here's what were interested in
now they provide you some information
and the first thing I want us to focus
on is there's a rate of change that they
give to you there's a rate of change
that they say in words have a look read
the first opening paragraph right and
they say this weird cube is shrinking I
don't know maybe it's like a cube of
sugar in a cup of tea or coffee or
something like that it's shrinking
what's the rate of change that they give
you in that first sentence the side
length this is important the side length
so this is the side leg right see that
it's decreasing bless you at a rate of 5
millimeters per minute okay so here's
what we going to do the first thing
we're gonna write is a rate of change
okay it's gonna be something rd
something if it's a rate of change it's
comparing it to the time so T's gonna be
in here somewhere
where's it going to go where do we
always put time it's gonna be on the
bottom all the rivers derivatives you've
seen here have that T down the bottom
okay up the top have a look at what is
the name of the variable that is
changing have a look carefully it's its
side length right that's what they've
said to us this side length they've
named X they could have called it s for
side I suppose but we'll go with X and
that's fine okay now is it getting
bigger or smaller it's getting smaller
so the rate should mean that it's a
decreasing function so what should the
sign of it be it should be it should be
negative because the thing is getting
smaller and smaller and smaller negative
and I'm gonna put the value at the front
which is 5 right and just beside it I'm
gonna put in the units just so I've got
it in my brain
I'm pretty sure it's millimeters per
minute this time isn't it but this is
what I was confusing with the previous
question okay okay now don't worry too
much about the scaffolding that's there
I think we can scaffold ourselves when
we have a look at part a it says find
the rate at which volume surface area
and edge lengths are decreasing when the
side length is 30 centimeters okay so
this is what I'm interested in when the
side length that's X is 30 weight
millimeters now they say centimeters
okay if you say so do note that by the
way it's really easy to get confused
with the unit's this is a rate of change
in millimeters per minute and this is
the length they've given us in
centimeters okay so in fact the first
thing I'm going to do is change that
into the correct units which is what is
that once I convert it to millimeters
that's 300 right okay we're ready to
rock and roll
now the first rate of change the easiest
one is the edge length think about this
right the edge length is just DX on DT
but you already know what that is don't
you
does it care what's happening like when
your whether you're big or your small
have a look at the question he says it's
changing at a it's not a variable rate
is it look again what's the word they
use it's a constant rate so no matter
what's going on up here no matter how
big or small you are this rate of change
will always be negative five okay is
that all right when you start looking at
the rest of the things as we did with
this volume right the other variables
are going to change at different rates
so let's first think about let's go up
in dimensions I guess this is a
one-dimensional thing let's go up to
surface area what is the surface area of
this shape hmm actually I might just
call it a four area well there are six
faces that are all identical and each
face solve them so six each face has an
area of x squared very good so when you
look at this
clear is that I can differentiate this
guy with respect to X because it's in
terms of X right so I could do that no
problem right
what is the derivative it's just 12x
thank you very much but I'm not
interested in DA on DX I'm interested in
DA on I want to I want a rate of change
right so it's with respect to time right
so in fact what I really want is da on
DT okay so what I'm going to need to do
as I did with my balloon is I'm going to
need to string together some derivatives
that will give me this okay something on
something times something else on
something right now you want your DA on
the top
you want your DT on the bottom have a
look at the information that you've got
what's the only appropriate choice to
put him in its DX right I already know
what da or DX is I just worked it out
its 12x and I also know what DX on DT is
because by definition according to the
question it's yeah negative five like so
okay so it's negative 60 X are you happy
with that that make sense yeah just
having a look to do hmm
yep that makes sense so you can see that
oh it said this a total age like oh it
says total edge length and I will come
to that later
okay let's let's sort this guy up so
when X is equal to here's what I've
worked it out here's my current moment
in time when x equals 300 when x equals
300 all I have to do is substitute into
this equation to get my actual rate of
change right da on DT equals can we do
the numbers I never give it up this I'll
give you the minus sign for free that's
how generous I am 6 times 3 is 18 how
many zeros am I gonna write on the end
three of them one two three now at this
point I'm going to give you a suggestion
okay you remember how we used to do put
your pens down from it we used to do
lots of areas with integrals do you know
over that and we
say area equals and then we go integrate
internet integrate we'd get to the
bottom and then we're like here's a
number and then we would just tack on
like units squared or something like
that right in this case I think this is
an appropriate time to say don't just
tack on some units actually say a
statement and here is why a crucial part
of this entire topic is interpretation
particularly interpreting things like
say that guy right what does that minus
sign mean why did we put on here in the
first place because it was our thing it
means it's decreasing so I want you to
show me that you understand what the
meaning of that is that it's decreasing
so here's what I'm going to do instead
of just tacking some units on the end of
this I'm gonna say therefore surface
area is and I'm going to use the word
decreasing this is my interpretation of
the negative sign at what are these
units in well 18,000 it's an area right
so it's not gonna be millimeters per
minute it's gonna be it's an area it's
an area big millimeters square per
minute if you're wondering why this
number 18,000 like wow that seems
astronomically large it's because
millimeters are very little units so
that's why it takes so many of them to
do anything okay all right last one to
answer this part this is part one when
the volume is changing as well what's
the volume of this shape just regular
volume not a rate of change just the
volume itself it's a cube so 2x cubed by
definition it's a key right so there's X
cubed just as before I can find a
derivative with respect to X that's easy
to do but what I really want is a
derivative with respect to time with
respect to T okay so therefore I'm going
to have to string together the
appropriate derivatives to get the
actual value I want okay